ralph waldo n'est pas considérée en
devient mère scolaire c'est un coup de
gueule et il n'est pas isolé
celui d'une infirmière scolaire au bout
du rouleau en 2002 conditions de travail
difficiles manque de moyens le mal être
au sein de cette profession à majorité
féminine dure depuis des décennies
l'un des premiers témoignages c'était en
1981 en charge de 1400 élèves
cette infirmière scolaire doit se rendre
disponible 24 heures sur 24
ça fait quand même 28 ans que je suis
sorti de l'école nous avons que de temps
en temps une fois par an une journée de
formation etc
on est seul on est isolé manque de
formation mais aussi effectif réduit
certaines doivent s'occuper de plusieurs
établissements en même temps notamment
en zone rurale
le rectorat a choisi de redéployer c'est
à dire on met une infirmière dans un
établissement scolaire des chapiteaux
rich et en plus on va l'envoyer sur
secteur
face à ce manque de reconnaissance les
infirmières scolaires crient leur colère
1998 des centaines d'entre elles
manifestent à paris
à l'origine de ce mouvement un problème
d'effectif le syndicat de la profession
réclame la création de 7500 postes
or le budget 81,18 prévoit seulement
l'an gauche de 300 infirmières scolaires
malgré ce coup de gueule les infirmières
scolaires ne sont pas entendues en 2001
nouveau ras-le-bol
toujours à paris les revendications
restent les mêmes plus de considération
mais aussi une revalorisation de leurs
salaires
on ne nous écoute et même en nous
humilient parce qu'aucun des ministères
la dénier même nous répondre ou nous
recevoir
les années passent et toujours la même
galère manque d'effectifs et de moyens
salaires bas surcharge de travail
en témoigne anne marie en 2005 cette
infirmière scolaire a en charge 17
établissements en même temps et nous
manque un du temps parce que l'on doit
être à plein d'endroits différents et
alors que la demande états est très
importante et c'est assez frustrant de
ne pas pouvoir répondre à la demande
la profession s'est retrouvé encore plus
fragilisés en 2020 en cause la crise du
coville 19 qui n'a fait que multiplier
les tâches des infirmières scolaires
une situation d'autant plus compliquée
qu'elle ne sont que sept mille 700 en
france pour 62 mille établissements de
l'éducation nationale
[Musique]